in this problem we're asked to figure
out the length of bc
we have a bunch of triangles here and
some lengths of sides and a couple of
right angles and so maybe we can
establish similarity between some of the
triangles there's actually three
different triangles that i can see here
this triangle this triangle and this
larger triangle if we can establish some
similarity here maybe we can use ratios
between sides somehow to figure out what
bc is so when you look at it you have a
right angle right over here yeah so in
triangle bdc you have one right angle in
triangle abc you have another right
angle if we can share if we can show
that they have another angle or another
corresponding set of angles that are
congruent to each other then we can show
that they're similar and actually both
of those triangles both b d c
and a b c
both share this angle right over here so
if they share that angle then they
definitely share two angles so they both
share that angle right over there let me
do that in a different color just for
just to make it different than those
right angles they both share that angle
there and so we know that two triangles
that have at least two of their angles
are
that have at least two congruent angles
they are going to be similar triangles
so we know we know that triangle i'll
write this triangle a b c
a b c we went from the unlabeled angle
to the right yellow right angle to the
orange angle so let me write it this way
went from the unlabeled angle right over
here to the orange angle or sorry to the
yellow angle i'm having trouble with
colors to the orange angle abc and we
want to do this very carefully here
because the same points or the same
vertices might not play the same role in
both triangles so we want to make sure
we're getting the similarity right
white vertex to the the 90 degree angle
vertex to the orange vertex that is
going to be similar to
to triangle
so which is the one that is neither
right angle so we're looking at the
smaller triangle right over here which
is the one that is neither a right angle
or the orange angle what's going to be
vertex b vertex b had the right angle
when you think about the larger triangle
but we haven't thought about just that
little angle right over there so we
start at vertex b then we're going to go
to the right angle the right angle is
vertex d
vertex d and then we go to vertex c
which is in orange so so we have shown
that they are similar and now that we're
that we know that they are similar we
can attempt to take ratios between the
sides
and so let's think about it we know what
the length of ac is ac is going to be
ac is going to be equal to eight six
plus two so we know that ac
ac what's the corresponding side on this
triangle right over here so you can
literally look at the letters a and c is
going to court is going to correspond to
b c the first and the third first and
the third a c is going to correspond to
b c
and what is and so this is interesting
because we're already involving bc and
so what is going to correspond to
and then if we look at bc on the larger
triangle so if we look at bc on the
larger triangle
bc
is going to correspond to what on the
smaller triangle is going to correspond
to dc
and it's good because we know what ac is
and we know what dc is and so we can
solve for bc so i want to take one more
step to show you what we just did here
because bc is playing two different
roles on this first statement right over
here we're thinking of bc
bc corresponds bc on our smaller
triangle corresponds to ac on our larger
triangle and then in our in the second
statement bc
on our larger triangle corresponds to dc
on our smaller triangle
so in both of these cases so these are
our larger triangles
and then these are this is from the
smaller triangle right over here
corresponding sides and this is a cool
problem because bc plays two different
roles in two in both triangles but now
we have enough information to solve for
bc we know that ac is equal to nine
we know that a oh sorry ac is equal to
eight
ac is equal to eight six plus two is
eight and we know that dc is equal to
two that's given and now we can cross
multiply eight times two is 16 is equal
to bc times bc is equal to bc
squared and so bc is going to be equal
to the principal root of 16 which is
four
b c
is equal to four
bc is equal to four and we're done and
the hardest part about this problem is
just realizing that bc plays two
different roles and just keeping your
head straight is just keeping your head
straight on those two different roles
and just to make it clear let me
actually draw these two triangles
separately so if i drew a b c separately
it would look like this
it would look like this so this is my
triangle
a
b
c
and then this is a right angle this is
our
orange angle
we know that the length of this side
right over here is eight and we know
that the length of this side will be
figured out through this problem is four
then if we wanted to draw bdc we would
draw it like this
so
bdc b dc looks like this
so this is b
d
c that's a little bit easier to
visualize because we've already this is
our right angle this is our orange angle
and this is four
and this right over here is two and i
did it this way to show you that you
kind of have to flip this triangle over
and rotate it just to have kind of a
similar orientation and then it might
make it look a little bit clearer so if
you found this part confusing i
encourage you to try to flip and rotate
bdc in such a way that it seems to look
a lot like abc and then this ratio
should hopefully make a lot more sense